bien monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
nous procédons aujourd'hui à une
audition pour suite à donner à l'enquête
de la Cour des comptes réalisées à la
demande de notre commission en
application de l'article 58 2 de la loi
organique relative aux lois de finance
sur les scénarios de financement des
collectivités territoriales nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir une nouvelle
fois Monsieur Pierre Moscovici premier
président de la Cour des comptes
accompagné de Monsieur Christian Charpy
président de la première chambre de la
Cour et de plusieurs magistrats qui ont
préparé cette enquête
ces dernières années ont vu de profondes
modifications des ressources des
collectivités locales caractérisées par
une stabilité alors une stabilité en
volume on va dire des transferts
financiers de l'État une diminution de
la fiscalité locale et un renforcement
de la péricquation l'autonomie fiscale
se réduit fortement et de nouvelles
propositions sont formulées dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques sur l'encadrement des
dépenses des collectivités locales une
réflexion doit donc être engagée sur la
réalité de leur charge de fonctionnement
elle est toujours engagée mais aussi
d'investissement qui détermineront leurs
besoins de financement et sur le panier
de ressources dont elle pourrait
bénéficier pour répondre aux éventuelles
prévisions aux évolutions
prévisionnelles pardon de leur charge
compte tenu de l'ampleur de ces
questions qui d'ailleurs agitent les
esprits depuis de bien nombreuses années
nous avons avec le rapporteur général et
mon collègue rapporteur spécial Charles
Gonnet choisi de confier à la Cour des
comptes une mission de réflexion
approfondie sur ce sujet je remercie les
magistrats de la Cour pour les échanges
nombreux que nous avons eu tout au long
de la préparation de leur rapport je
rappelle à chacun que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse et retransmise sur
le site internet du Sénat je donne donc
tout de suite la parole au président
Moscovici
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général monsieur rapporteur
de la mission en relation avec les
collectivités territoriales mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui pour présenter le
rapport de la Cour des comptes
je pense que les micro-ondes marche pas
sur les scénaires d'évolution du
financement des collectivités
territoriales conformément la mission
constitutionnelle d'assistance de la
courroie Parlement à laquelle je suis
très attaché vous avez demandé au mois
de janvier 2022 comme vous l'avez dit
cette enquête thématique que je crois
très importantes pour l'avenir de nos
finances publiques et en particulier des
finances publiques des collectivités
territoriales sa publication
intervient un moment opportun puisque
l'examen
discussion parlementaire sur la loi de
finance et sur la programmation des
finances publiques débutent dans l'autre
assemblée nous avions en effet demandé
de rendre ce rapport à ce moment pour
qu'il puisse précisément éclairer le
débat budgétaire au terme d'une
instruction menée donc avec diligence
qui a associé à trois reprises vous
l'avez signalé certains membres éminents
de votre commission donc il y a eu une
interaction entre nous
je suis heureux de pouvoir vous en
partager nos conclusions qui sont je
l'espère et je le crois de nature à
éclairé précisément vos débats et vos
propres arbitrages ce rapport a été
délibéré parce que nous appelons chez
nous une formation inter juridiction
faire une formation associant des
chambres de la Cour des comptes et des
chambres régionales des comptes ce qui
était indispensable pour avoir le double
éclairage à la fois national et
territorial il lui était absurde je
crois de le faire uniquement depuis
Paris en quelque sorte pour vous le
présenter sont présents à mes côtés le
président de la première chambre
Christian charpip qui a présidé cette
formation ainsi que l'équipe des
rapporteurs madame ligno Leloup
rapporteur général de la formation
commune madame Falzone Allard monsieur
Lyon et en tant que contre rapporteur
monsieur glimet et je veux les remercier
avant toute chose pour leur travail qui
a été considérable et que je crois assez
remarquable ce rapport elle demande du
Sénat intervient dans un contexte
particulier pour les finances publiques
locales la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation sur la résidence principale
et la baisse des impôts de production
ont en effet profondément modifié le
panier de recettes de tous les niveaux
de collectivité depuis 2021 avec
notamment vous le savez bien une par
croissante des impôts nationaux partagés
avec l'État il en est résulté pour les
exécutifs locaux une certaine baisse de
maîtrise de leur financement de même la
loi de programmation de finances
publiques qui s'achève avait prévu un
mécanisme de contractualisation entre
l'État et les grandes collectivités
territoriales visant à encadrer
l'évolution de leurs dépenses
ce mécanisme est connu sous le nom de
contrat de Cahors il a été suspendu avec
la crise sanitaire mais le projet de
nouvelle loi de programmation des
finances publiques prévoir un mécanisme
inspiration comparable pour faire
participer les collectivités
territoriales au redressement les
finances publiques enfin le retour de
l'inflation créé une tension et
disons-le une inquiétude nouvelle sur
les budgets des collectivités voilà pour
le contexte ce rapport que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui n'a pas vocation
à traiter de ces deux derniers sujets
mais dans la perspective de la
définition d'une trajectoire soutenable
des finances publiques à laquelle vous
le comprenez la cour est très attachée
il vise à examiner les évolutions
possibles de des modalités de
financement des petites territoriales
les régions les départements les
communes et leurs groupements
le rapport dont je vais vous présenter
les grands messages mais d'abord en
évidence l'unité de réformer le système
de financement des collectivités
territoriales ensuite il débattra il
présente plusieurs options possibles de
financement qu'il vous appartiendra de
débattre à partir de quelle la cour pour
répondre à une demande explicite de
votre commission je le précise dresse un
scénario de réforme possible nous
n'aurions pas forcément fait
d'initiative mais nous répondons là à
votre demande enfin il identifie
plusieurs conditions le dialogue le
partage de données la simplification
l'anticipation qui sont à nos yeux
nécessaires pour une nouvelle
gouvernance des finances publiques
locales qui soient la base
d'impact de confiance renouvelée entre
l'État les élus et les citoyens quelques
mots pour commencer sur la situation
financière des collectivités
territoriales et sur les évolutions
récentes des ressources locales
comme nous l'avons déjà souligné dans
notre rapport sur les finances publiques
locales la Cour observe qu'après une
année 2020 marquée par la crise
sanitaire les collectivités ont vu leur
situation financière s'améliorer
incontestablement en 2021 la reprise de
l'activité
et les crédits consacrés aux mesures de
soutien collectivité en 2020 et 2021 par
l'État à hauteur de 2,6 milliards
d'euros l'auront permis d'atteindre un
niveau d'épargne supérieur à celui
d'avant la crise soit
41,4 milliards d'euros leur situation
financière est favorable avec un
excellent de 4,7 milliards d'euros fin
le contexte du retour de l'inflation qui
pèse vous le savez bien sur les achats
des collectivités et la hausse du point
d'indice des fonctionnaires décidé pour
maintenir leur pouvoir d'achat vont
probablement modifier cette situation
favorable en 2022 et 2023 même si les
ressources fiscales des collectivités
notamment les taxes foncières s'agissant
du bloc communal sont-elles dynamiques
le manque de lisibilité d'une part
l'évolution profonde des sources de
financement d'autre part appelle
désormais une réflexion d'ensemble sur
les finances locales des ressources
issues d'une sédimentation historique
sans révision d'ensemble rendre
aujourd'hui ce financement peu
compréhensible à la fois pour les
responsables locaux et pour les
contribuables avec des inégalités qui se
creusent entre les territoires la
structure de financement des
collectivités a connu des réformes
nombreuses affectant les trois
principales ressources fiscalité locale
fiscalité nationale et dotation ces
réformes n'ont pas toujours été
accompagnées d'une réflexion sur le mode
de financement des collectivités
l'augmentation de la part des impôts
nationaux partagés avec l'État avec le
transfert des parts de TVA décidé en
2017 a en partie brouillé la distinction
entre un pot nationaux et
la suppression de la part régionale de
la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises la CVAE à partir de 2021
conduit également à ce que les régions
ne disposent plus de ressources
directement attachées à l'activité
économique sur le territoire quant au
département ils ont perdu en réalité
l'essentiel de leur pouvoir de taux avec
le transfert des taxes foncières aux
communes enfin avec la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation sur les résidences
principales la fiscalité du bloc
communal repose désormais principalement
sur le propriétaire du foncier et non
plus sur l'habitant voilà un constat
rapide mais qui me semble assez clair
ce système de financement est assez un
aliment critiquée les principes
fondateurs des finances locales ont en
effet à travers ces évolutions perdus de
leur pertinence en raison de la part
croissante de la fiscalité nationale au
sein de leurs ressources propres
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
telles que mesurer par les ratiaux
définis en 2004 progresse mais ça ne
rend pas compte de la perception par les
élus locaux d'une perte de maîtrise de
leurs ressources la péréquation des
ressources entre collectivités souffrent
d'un manque d'objectifs clairement
défini et évaluer et la solidarité
horizontale reste elle trop peu
développée au sein de chaque niveau de
collectivité
les modalités de compensation des
transferts de compétences ont conduit à
émietter les transferts de fiscalité au
prix de la lisibilité d'ensemble enfin
le système de répartition des dotations
et subventions apparaît complexe peu
prévisible sans corriger non plus
suffisamment les écarts de ressources au
total alors que les élus que vous êtes
et dont vous êtes aussi des
représentants ont plus que jamais besoin
de pouvoir se projeter et anticiper à la
mesure
que leur rôle d'investisseur public
prend l’ampleur le système de
financement de son côté est devenu peu
lisible faiblement maîtrisé et ne
garantit pas l'équilibre des budgets
locaux
ce qui a pour conséquence qu'une
réflexion globale sur l'adéquation entre
les missions et les ressources est
aujourd'hui nécessaire pour cela et
c'est mon second point nous avons
souhaité vous présenter il me semble que
c'était la réponse à votre demande trois
options polaires comme dit le rapport
selon chaque type de financement et qui
repose sur plusieurs critères
d'appréciation à partir de cette grille
d'analyse la cour présente un scénario
de réforme possible sur le financement
des collectivités territoriales pour le
rendre plus lisible et plus résilient
nous sommes inspirés de modèles retenus
à l'étranger et après échange avec les
associations les locaux car nous le
conflit bien sûr nous avons identifié
trois critères d'évaluation de la
réforme du financement des collectivités
premier critère c'est l'équilibre pour
renforcer la lisibilité et la
prévisibilité des financements pour
garantir la soutenabilité des finances
locales et la maîtrise de leur
ressources deuxième principe c'est au
deuxième critère la territorialisation
des ressources pour renforcer le lien
entre territoire et contribuable et
aussi la capacité d'action des
collectivités enfin troisième critère
c'est la solidarité pour réduire les
inégalités entre collectivités par une
répartition équitable à la base des
ressources jusqu'à des mécanismes
correcteurs de péréquation
pour susciter la réflexion je vous l'ai
dit il y a un instant la Cour a examiné
de trois options que nous appelons
polaires car elles sont réparties sur
des pôles il peut y avoir des
intermédiaires sans doute en portant à
son maximum la part de financement des
collectivités résultant d'un des trois
types de ressources
soit un financement essentiellement par
des ressources locales des impôts locaux
des redevances dont l'objectif principal
d'une véritable territorialisation des
ressources soit un financement accru par
des impôts nationaux partagés par
lesquels les collectivités gagneraient
en prévisibilité en dynamisme de
recettes soit enfin un financement
renforcé par des dotations de l'État
dans le respect bien sûr du principe
d'autonomie financière des collectivités
je précise pour éviter tout malentendu
que c'était un polaire sont
volontairement théoriques et qu'il
permet d'une part à nos yeux
d'identifier le bon curseur d'une
réforme du modèle de financement quel
type de ressources pour quel niveau de
collectivité et d'autre part de définir
les principes fondamentaux de cette
réforme au terme de cette analyse la
Cour constate que les marges de
progression des ressources locales dans
le financement des collectivités
territoriales sont désormais limitées
sauf à bien sûr recréer un impôt
résidentiel touchant le plus grand
nombre ce qui relève d'un choix
politique lourd par ailleurs la Cour
estime que ces marches seraient
essentiellement mobilisable pour le bloc
communal donc pas pour les autres
l'augmentation du partage des impôts
nationaux est une option possible en
mobilisant sans doute d'autres impôts
nationaux que ceux aujourd'hui partagé
ainsi
si la part de TVA partagée sans doute
est encore un peu augmenté comme
d'ailleurs annoncé le gouvernement pour
compenser la suppression progressive de
la cbae il serait dangereux de l'autre
côté de privé l'état d'une ressource
dynamique d'autres impôts nationaux
pourraient être sollicités comme l'impôt
sur le revenu ou l'impôt sur les
sociétés à l'instar de ce que font
d'ailleurs certains de nos voisins
à l'inverse la Cour estime qu'il serait
préférable de concentrer sur l'état les
impôts liés à l'énergie ou au véhicules
automobiles afin de pouvoir mobiliser
plus facilement cette fiscalité dans le
cadre de la transition écologique
nécessaire enfin tout en notant que
certains pays ont largement recours et
que ce type de financement paraît adapté
pour certaines dépenses décentralisées
la Cour constate que l'augmentation de
la part des dotations dans le
financement des côtés locales
resteraient contraintes par les ratios
d'automie financières prévues par la loi
et qu'elle ne remporterait pas
l'adhésion des associations d'élus
tout ça veut dire que ce n'est pas
simple en réalité à partir de ces
signaux polaires la cour tire des
principes qui devraient éclairer une
réforme du cadre des financements des
comités territoriales le premier
principe d'une réforme soit de
contribuer à la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales qu'un
système de financement qui renforce la
lisibilité et qui facilite l'exercice
des responsabilités ensuite afin de
renforcer ce qui est indispensable le
lien entre le contribuable et le
territoire il convient de recentrer la
fiscalité locale restante sur le bloc
communal échelon de proximité
seul doté d'une compétence générale et
de supprimer autant que possible les
multi-affectations d'Apollo pour tous
les échelons il est prioritaire de
mettre les ressources en adéquation avec
les missions exercées quelques exemples
sur ce dernier point
les missions sociales des départements
exigent plus de stabilité plus de
solidarité nationale dans leur
financement nous l'avons souligné à
travers toute une série de rapports
si on se réfère à une situation actuelle
marquée par des fluctuations importantes
des DMTO dans le temps et selon les
territoires par ailleurs les régions
dont le rôle dans le développement
économique est croissant devrait pouvoir
bénéficier de ressources en lien avec
l'activité économique enfin les critères
de répartition des ressources entre
collectivités ne devrait à nos yeux plus
être liés à des situations
héritées du passé avec un risque majeur
qui serait de consolider les inégalités
mais elles doivent se fonder sur les
besoins des territoires évalués à partir
de critères sociaux économiques
à partir de ces options polaires je le
dis tout de suite en prenant en compte
limite la Cour a élaboré un scénario
possible je dis bien possible
équilibrer par rapport au niveau de
collectivité pour l'État une réforme
pragmatique du financement des
collectivités locales devraient viser à
combiner les divers ressources en
conciliant les objectifs si je dis
d'autonomie et de solidarité et en
priorisant différemment ces enjeux selon
les niveaux de collectivité et leur
mission
le scénario qui vous est présenté à
titre illustratif et je prends mes
précautions par la Cour conduirait à
recentrer la fiscalité locale sur le
blog communal pour plus d'autonomie de
responsabilité
à mettre en place un système plus
solidaire de financement des
départements pour leur permettre de
faire face à leur dépense sociale et de
renforcer le financement des régions par
la fiscalité nationale économique qui
nous semble qu'il y a une cohérence en
tout cas de principe sa licence des
communes tout d'abord le scénario
intègre suppression de la CVAE et vise à
recentrer toute la fiscalité fiscalité
locale restant sur le bloc communal ce
qui veut dire les taxes foncières
la taxe d'habitation sur les ressources
secondaires mais également les y faire
donc bénéficier aujourd'hui les
départements et les régions
ces recettes seraient complétées par une
dotation de fonctionnement le bloc local
dans ce scénario verrai son ratio
d'autonomie progressées de 70 et
76%, les DMTO un polycal aujourd'hui
partagé serait transformée en impôt
national affecté au bloc communal avec
des critères de répartition qui
permettrait une affectation plus
équilibrée en fonction des
caractéristiques socio-éclamiques et non
plus en fonction du lieu de transactions
immobilières qui est source de
déformation pour les départements le CEO
proposé conduit à affecter un panier
d'impôts nationaux TVA taxe spéciale sur
les conventions d'assurance mais aussi
une fraction d'impôt sur le revenu et à
créer une dotation d'action sociale pour
sécuriser et garantir le financement des
dépenses sociales et départements enfin
les régions pourrait être financées par
deux impôts nationaux partagés
à dominante économique la TVA et l'impôt
sur les sociétés
dans cette réforme le partage de la
fiscalité nationale augmenterait mais sa
répartition reposerait sept fois
progressivement sur des critères qui
reflètent bien les caractéristiques
sociales et économiques des territoires
et non sur la recette collectée
localement ou sur les recettes
historiques remplacées ce scénario est
en effet fondé sur une part croissante
de TVA 24% lieu de 20%. il inclut
également une un partage d'une fraction
de 12% d'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
régions et de 10% d'impôt sur le revenu
pour les départements le partage de
l'islière permet à nos yeux d'associer
la dynamique
d'impôts nationaux cohérent avec leur
mission en lissant les évolutions par la
diversification du panier de recette
dernier point
je vais pas évoqué jusqu'à présent les
dotations de l'État seraient
rationalisées selon trois finalités
assurer la transition vers un nouveau
mode de financement pour les régions
financer l'action sociale pour les
départements assurer l'équilibre
financier du bloc communal par ailleurs
le scénario devrait viser également une
simplification en supprimant notamment
les compensations de fiscalité anciennes
ce scénario je le redis possible et
illustratif répond aux trois objectifs
d'équilibre financier de
territorialisation des ressources pour
le blog communal de solidarité en
fonction de la rationalisation des
dotations et la clé de répartition des
impôts nationaux
ce scénario ne sort pas de nulle part il
a été présenté aux différentes
associations d'élus nous avons senti un
point de sensibilité particulière
concernant la proposition de transformer
les dnto en apôt National partagé
l'Association des départements de France
a notamment critiqué cette orientation
considérant qu'elle conduirait à
supprimer le dernier apot territorialisé
des départements mais c'était une
logique de cohérence que nous avons
voulue présenter trois raisons je veux
justifier notre choix on explique cette
orientation proposée par la cour mais
aussi par d'autres d'abord les DMTO sont
une ressource très instable en forte
croissance en 2020 et 2021
ils avaient vu leurs produits
s'effondrer je vous le rappelle de 40%
après la crise de 2008-2009 c'était une
crise financière et les perspectives ne
sont pas favorables pour les prochains
mois ensuite c'est un impôt qui crée de
fortes inégalités car l'assiette
territoriale est très signalement
répartie malgré les dispositifs de
péréquation horizontale l'écart de
recettes par habitant va tout de même de
1 à 7 selon les départements j'ai envie
de dire vos départements enfin si
l'assiette est territorialisée le taux
et lui aujourd'hui largement uniforme
aucune modulation possible pour les
communes et la quasi-totalité des
départements ont adopté le taux plafond
mais je le répète
le scénario présenté par la Cour est
illustratif il n'est pas exclusif
d'autres options possibles des
évolutions ils visent à vous donner
quelques idées quelques repères quelques
principes pour nourrir votre propre
réflexion à partir de votre expérience
qui est grande pour la cour
ce scénario doit être vu comme un cadre
de référence en vue d'un ajustement
progressif de financement rien de plus
rien de moins voilà pour le fond sur la
méthode au delà de ce scénario proposé
la cour propose son rapport de
renouveler la gouvernance des finances
publiques locales et
identifient les conditions d'une réforme
en effet à nos yeux une réforme du
financement des collectivités
territoriales ne sera possible que par
le rétablissement du dialogue entre
l'État les représentants des
collectivités locales dans la
préparation des textes financiers
nationaux ce qui veut dire que nos yeux
est insuffisant et pas une concertation
mieux structurée est fondée sur un plus
fort partage des données sur les
finances locales avec une application
forte du Parlement ce qu'il a encore
vous dire qu'il y a des marges de
progression
dans son rapport sur la gouvernance des
finances publiques de novembre 2020 qui
reste très actuel la Cour avait proposé
la création d'une instance pérenne de
dialogue entre l'État et les autres
administrations publiques sécurité
sociale et collective et locale pour
examiner les grands textes financiers en
amont de leur présentation Parlement
en complément la cour swine dans ce
rapport la cité d'une instance pérenne
spécifique consacrée au finances locales
à laquelle serait présenté les textes
financiers intéressants les
collectivités locales mais aussi les
modalités de compensation des
suppressions d'impôts ou de transfert de
compétences et les règles d'évolution ou
de partage des impôts
cet instant pourrait être soit le Comité
des finances locales mais profondément
rénové soit une autorité indépendante
nouvelle dotée de moyens d'expertise
renforcés
une réforme du financement des
collectivités territoriales devrait
également proposer sur quelques
principes forts la simplification pour
plus de lisibilité de responsabilité la
prévisibilité et l'équilibre financiers
en tout cas quel que soit le seigneur de
réforme choisie il sera à nos yeux
nécessaires de rationaliser
l'affectation de la fiscalité pour
éviter les multi affectateurs et pour
procéder à la révision de trop ancien
qui complexifie le financement des
collectivités et partant nuisent à la
démocratie locale par ailleurs
l’équilibre dont la durée entre la
dynamique des recettes et des dépenses
de chaque niveau de collectivité devrait
être recherchée avec des clauses de
rendez-vous au niveau national et une
refonte progressive des critères de
répartition afin de mieux tenir compte
des charges à partir d'indicateurs
socio-écanis des territoires
même si chacun sait ici que le projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques n'a pas encore été voté
je veux en dire un mot tout de même je
persiste à dire que nous avons besoin de
cette vision plus réelle notamment pour
gagner en transparence et en
prévisibilité je m'inquiète de la
possibilité de l'inexistence d'une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
qui nous priveraient d'une encre
extrêmement utile une bonne loi de
programmation des finances publiques
devrait contenir des engagements
réciproques entre l'État et les
collectivités à la fois pour renforcer
la prévisibilité des ressources locales
et pour définir après une concertation
approfondie avec les représentants des
collectivités les modalités de
participation des collectivités locales
au redressement des finances publiques
dernier point mais non négligeable
l'analyse des données et le partage de
l'information sont à renforcer un
dialogue plus équilibré entre l'État et
que le Tilton exige des outils partagés
et des données de qualité facilement
accessibles sur les recettes et les
dépenses et ça nécessite de développer
des capacités d'analyse au niveau
national
au niveau local qui aujourd'hui sont
insuffisantes en tout cas ainsi en
définitive le rapport de la Cour tire de
ses analyses 7 recommandations
essentielle la première visa renouveler
le gouvernance finance locale en créant
l'autorité indépendante ou en réformant
en profondeur le Comité des finances
locales les six autres recommandations
reprennent les améliorations évoquées
pour rendre le système de financement
des collectivités plus lisibles et plus
résilients notamment clarifiant la
responsabilité sur les apôts locaux en
simplifiant le partage des apolationaux
et en prenant mieux en compte la réalité
socio-économique dans la répartition des
impôts nationaux
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs voici la présentation du
rapport que vous avez demandé qu'il en
épuise ni les analyses ni les
recommandations toutefois s'il fallait
en retenir deux choses seulement les
voici tout d'abord c'est que le système
de financement des collectivités
régionales ont à montrer ses limites
alors que des évolutions fiscales
majeures restructures de distribution
des recettes nous avons proposé des
critères objectifs méthodologiques
transparent pour guider le débat qu'il
vous appartient désormais de mener
encore une fois c'est la portée et c'est
aussi la limite de notre propre travail
ensuite et c'est une des conclusions
essentielles de notre rapport ce nouveau
modèle doit précisément faire l'objet
d'une concertation structurée autour
d'objectif commun pour garantir la
lisibilité pour le citoyen la
prévisibilité pour les collectivités la
soutenabilité pour les finances
publiques
j'insiste sur ce dernier point pour
finir la durabilité la construction de
ce nouveau mail doit aussi permettre de
construire une trajectoire de finance
locale comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire en présentant en juillet dernier le
rapport sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques
toutes les administrations toutes
doivent prendre par la réduction du
déficit et l'effort de chacun doit être
posé clairement au début de chaque cycle
budgétaire merci de votre attention je
me tiens si vous le permettez cette
fois-ci ça fait vraiment moi aussi
partager mon temps
avec ce qui m'entoure et qui ont élaboré
ce rapport qui ne connaissent donc en
profondeur encore davantage que moi que
je remercie à nouveau pour ce travail
sur utile à votre disposition pour vos
questions donc si vous voulez bien nous
ferons à devoir avec le président Charpy
qui a présidé la fige formation cage
audition ces travaux les concertations
pour des
précisions qui seront sans doute utiles
et nécessaires
merci
merci monsieur le Président
merci d'avoir fait aussi ce travail de
synthèse car plus un rapport touche des
sujets complexes plus la synthèse est
complexe pas nature et ne doit pas être
une nierdulcorer ni raccourcis bien
entendu alors je voudrais tout d'abord
vous dire que c'est une audition qui
n'est pas tout à fait traditionnelle
elle est traditionnelle dans le sens où
évidemment c'est une réponse à l'article
58 2 à une demande de la commission des
finances que nous avons exprimé mais
elle n'est pas traditionnelle parce que
traditionnellement dans une audition
vous auriez dans la salle des
représentants des associations d'élus
concernées par le sujet qui serait à
même de pouvoir répondre alors nous ne
l'avons pas souhaité parce que si nous
avions fait ça il nous fallait prévoir
une demi-journée d'abord et ça a été
extrêmement complexe à organiser et
d'organiser le débat donc nous avons
souhaité dans un premier temps qu'il y
ait un échange entre la cour et
l'ensemble des sénateurs sachant que
dans un deuxième temps nous aurons bien
sûr à avoir un débat avec des
associations d'élus pour ce qui nous
concerne avant même de remettre
nous-même en tant que conseiller
spéciaux rapporteur spéciaux Charles
Guénet et moi-même un rapport sur le sur
le sujet bien donc sujet particulier
sujet particulier aussi puisqu'il s'agit
d'un sujet qui ne touche pas directement
aux missions de l'État mais directement
au financement des collectivités locales
qui est un sujet
un peu différent de ce que sont
d'habitude les enquêtes en 58 2
deuxième troisième sujet c'est un sujet
impossible
d'un sujet impossible si bien pour ça
qu'on vous l'a confié
c'est un sujet impossible
nous le savons tous
quel que soit
le type de collectivité
quel que soit le type d'association
d'élus
tout le monde est là pour reconnaître
unanimement que le système
arrive à son terme
que depuis des années en Rafistol à coup
d'amendements de dernière minute pour
essayer de sauver des collectivités qui
seront en difficulté etc
mais on sait tous qu'on est au bout du
ça c'est la seule chose je crois qu'il
soit partagée par tous
et la deuxième chose qui est partagée
par tous c'est que dès qu'on touche à
quoi que ce soit c'est non
globalement je dis ça globalement on va
dire que c'est très compliqué d'ouvrir
ce débat le constater et nous nous
constatons avec Charles depuis bien
longtemps chaque fois qu'une proposition
arrive il est rare qu'elle suscite un
sentiment de soutien immédiat en tout
cas bon
des remerciements
pour toutes l'équipe qui a bien voulu se
charger de ce dossier alors les
présidents Charpy entre participer
également je salue madame l'ignot Leloup
rapporteur principal sur ce document et
l'ensemble évidemment des membres de la
Cour qui ont participé à cet exercice et
donc je les remercie parce que
il y a une phase ou une partie du
dossier qui est assez classique
c'est-à-dire la comparaison
internationale l'état des lieux tout
ceci est très utile toujours important
de les avoir mais c'est la partie la
plus simple sur l'état des lieux faut
dire que globalement tout le monde peut
avoir des positions
comment dire qui conforte
cet état des lieux par contre
la cour et vous l'avez d'ailleurs
vous-même signalez à bien voulu avancer
à la fois des scénarios polaires qui
étaient la vision que la Cour avait pour
essayer de situer les sujets mais à bien
voulu aussi tenter une incursion dans
une proposition
et ça je crois que c'est important c'est
évidemment ça fera réagir ça suscitera
peut-être pas aujourd'hui mais comme
tout le monde aura eu le temps de bien
intégrer les propositions c'est un
nombre de remarques et c'est bien
naturel mais je remercie la cour d'avoir
fait cet exercice d'essayer de proposer
un premier cadre
qui comme toujours en premier cadre à
vocation a évoluer vous l'avez dit à ne
pas être en cadre de référence mais
c'est tout à fait tout à fait importante
je voudrais dire que et vous l'avez
aussi dit en
substance
il est important de remettre le
Parlement
dans la boucle de cette réflexion
il n'y a pas ici je crois de sénateur
qui ne puisse s'étonner que finalement
aujourd'hui l'État négocie directement
avec les associations d'élus et le
Parlement est saisi finalement d'une
espèce de proposition conjointe ou d'une
proposition de l'État après concertation
et le rôle des parlementaires apparaît
par rapport à ce qu'il appelait dans le
passé un peu plus pauvre aujourd'hui
et je crois que sur ce sujet ou de toute
façon personne aucune association d'élus
et
ne posera le sujet de manière claire de
manière globale mais le posera avec son
angle de vue ce qui est normal
il est normal que le Parlement se
saisisse de cette question et pose sur
la table des éléments qui seront
discutés qui seront approuvés pour
certains qui sont mis en cause par
d'autres peu importe si je crois notre
rôle et je voudrais rappeler d'ailleurs
que ce rôle là a été encore une fois
rappelé par le président du Sénat
récemment en mettant en place
une mission décentralisation
mission des centralisation dans laquelle
la question financière
est clairement identifiée et je rappelle
que notre rapporteur général et donne un
déco rapporteur de cette mission
décentralisation et je pense qu'il
trouvera là comme nous tous des éléments
pour réfléchir comment améliorer la
décentralisation ou accentuer ou
accélérer la décentralisation dans notre
pays voilà les quelques éléments que je
voulais en tant que président
développé devant vous je vais donner la
parole tout de suite monsieur le
rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président je vais évidemment
m'associer aux propos et aux
remerciements à tous les membres de la
cour autour de vous puisque c'est un
travail dont nous avons eu à connaître
non pas pour en partager la totalité
c'est pas le c'est pas l'objectif ni des
travaux ni des orientations mais nous
avons eu des temps d'échanges réguliers
vous l'avez dit c'est un c'est un
document
qui n'a pas vocation à être exclusif
et qui a surtout vocation comme la dit à
l'instant le président Claude Raynal à
mettre
le plus sereinement possible dans des
temps pourtant bien difficile le dossier
de la finalement des évolutions fiscales
financières des collectivités
territoriales et locales sur la table
donc vraiment un grand merci pour
les le travail sur
le financement des collectivités locales
qui effectivement à l'ancienne
sédimentation enfin l'appel comme ça
c'est faudrait presque géologue
aujourd'hui plutôt que
féru de finance publique parce que ça
devient bien compliqué de s'y retrouver
et
vous avez évoqué les objectifs en
matière de lisibilité de prévisibilité
je crois que c'est effectivement
important vous posez des scénarios que
vous avez qualifiés de polaire ils ont
d'abord le mérite d'être posé sur la
table de d'apporter des éléments de
réponse selon les cas moi je ferai juste
parce que chacune et chacun d'entre nous
va avoir
envie de s'exprimer je ferai simplement
une remarque sur le scénario qualifié
d'intermédiaire que que vous proposez
dont dont je redis que de mon point de
vue elle mérite à la fois d'ouvrir et de
nourrir le débat et le fait de
concentrer la fiscalité locale sur le
bloc communal c'est bien ça reste
modeste on l'a vu vous avez expliqué que
globalement il y aurait de l'ordre d'un
milliard de de ressources
supplémentaires en transférrant les y
faire mais et vous l'avez dit et vous
avez d'ailleurs posé sur les DMTO la
place la réaction des départements cette
assurément un sujet qui fait déjà réagir
puisque finalement les départements se
verraient eux privés de de leur dernière
impôts locales mais je pense que au-delà
de de poser un problème de principe ça
peut soulever d'autres difficultés
compte tenues de l'importance de cette
impôt dans dans leur système de
péréquation est-ce que je voulais enfin
dire c'est moi je partage en fait la
double ambition
qui est affichée de rationaliser
fiscalité locale et notamment de faire
en sorte de supprimer les
multi-affectations mais également de
simplifier avec de la fiscalité partagée
avec une fraction unique par un pot et
par niveau de collectivité maintenant
les éléments sont posés sur la table
vous l'avez dit
à plusieurs reprises je crois que
nous devons maintenant
nous saisir évidemment au Parlement et
peut-être en premier lieu ici on est
bien dans notre rôle de ce rapport mais
je pense que le mot dialogue
échange partage ces trois mots vont être
soit des valeurs cardinales pour
construire un chemin
soit s'ils ne sont pas mis en oeuvre et
notamment le mot dialogue dont j'ai
quand même découvert qu'il était
aujourd'hui utilisé puisqu'on a eu droit
à une nouveauté dans le cadre de la
préparation budgétaire avec les fameux
dialogues de Bercy
ça Bercy et dialogue paraît tellement
contraire
à l'opinion publique en tous les cas
jusqu'à maintenant à beaucoup de
parlementaires que on se dit que c'est
le c'est peut-être la première marche
voyons-y une comment dirais-je un motif
d'optimisme et il va nous falloir les
uns les autres nous être à la tâche elle
est effectivement pas évidente mais
comme toute réforme je terminerai par là
dans une réforme on ne peut pas si on
modifie des paradigmes
il faut essayer de sortir par le haut
mais il faut aussi sortir des postures
qui consistent à dire qu'on ne garde
tout ce qui nous convient on enlève ce
qui nous convient pas et on rajoute on
est aujourd'hui dans un une période
difficile vous l'avez dit pour les
finances publiques et je crois aussi
qu'il va falloir le concilier avec
l'effort collectif de redressement des
comptes publics auxquels je partage en
tous les cas ce que vous avez dit
personne ne doit s'en exonérer
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
j'ai donné la parole au Rapporteur
spécial Charles Gonnet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Président
mes chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs de la cour
simplement je dois dire je pense que le
président Rénaldo aussi intervenu en
qualité de rapator spécial à travers ses
propos et je voudrais dire que son
analyse ne va parfaitement je crois que
c'est un travail transpartisan et je
crois que j'enlèverai aucun mot à ce
qu'il a pu dire simplement peut-être je
vais m'attarder sur les choses que je
n'ai pas trouvé dans le rapport et que
j'aurais aimé voir mais j'aurais pas que
ce soit pris comme quelque chose de
négatif aussi préalablement je vais
quand même dire que
je trouvais que ce rapport était plutôt
excellent et j'ai trouvé que la qualité
de l'analyse était très bonne la
méthodologie aussi et je pense que je
crois que c'est un rapport qui devrait
faire date
bon ces choses là étant dites
y compris y compris dans les y compris
dans les scénarios
qui ont été assez audacieux vous avez
évoqué d'ailleurs celui du DMTO vous
avez vous-même dit que cette audace
était quelquefois aller un peu au-delà
du consensus et ça j'en conviens non
simplement peut-être j'aurais aimé que
le constat de l'obsolescence du système
actuel
sera peut-être un peu plus
prononcé parce que je crois qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de pédagogie à faire
à ce niveau là
lorsqu'on voit ce qui nous est réclamé
et peut-être des des retours sur des
choses qui à mon avis ne sont plus à
notre portée
et aussi peut-être et plus plus
complètement
j'aurais aimé qu'on puisse trouver des
une conclusion et une élaboration plus
importante parce que en fait vous avez
beaucoup travaillé sur la ressource
elle-même les ressources nouvelles etc
et en fait on s'aperçoit que désormais
on a une confusion on aura une confusion
entre les dotations et la fiscalité
puisque la fiscalité lorsqu'elle devient
nationale et qu'elle est partagée ce
sont des dotations et cette confusion
nous aurait pu nous obliger à aller
au-delà et donc nous dire que lorsqu'on
passe d'un système reposant sur la
richesse potentielle et
l'atterritorialisation et qu'on va vers
un système d'impôts nationaux ça impose
pour réfléchissent beaucoup plus
fortement à la notion de charge réelle
qui devrait la base de la répartition
etc alors vous l'avez exquisé mais vous
vous n'avez pas osé y aller mais je le
conçois parce que ça oblige à trouver la
maille à travailler les critères comment
on passe d'un système à un autre et
finalement comme on passe d'une
territorialisation des ressources
peut-être à celle de la performance de
la dépense publique avait on fait avec
ce qu'on a enfin etc et c'est assez
compliqué alors
je veux dire vous n'êtes pas critiquable
parce que comme ça a été dit d'autres
ont refusé l'obstacle ne serait-ce que
les parlementaires eux-mêmes les
associations des lieux aussi alors
peut-être est-ce que ça appelle un
second rapport on peut le penser voilà
c'était cet aspect là parce que je fais
partie de ceux qui sont convaincus que
ce système obligera à revoir la notion
de répartition des charges lorsqu'on
territorialisait bon bah il fallait une
péréquation énorme qui n'est pas
acceptée et si on noter rien
territorialise plus il faut avoir un
nouveau système c'est celui des charges
réelles que des collectivités
alors en revanche je voudrais apporter
un bon point si je peux me permettre
enfin c'est
ce la rubrique sur la nouvelle
gouvernance qui en laquelle je crois
beaucoup et où vous êtes allés quand
même assez loin sur ce sujet en
proposant soit
un ensemble d'experts mixé avec d'autres
soit une évolution des CFN et je crois
que c'est le corollaire au système que
vers lequel nous allons et il faut
absolument qu'on mette en place cette
nouvelle gouvernance systémique on
l'appelle comme ça et je suis avec le
double rôle que vous avez évoqué à la
fois le rôle de conseil de et ensuite un
peu comme des pays
qui qui nous borde aussi une notion de
partage ensuite entre les deux et je
crois que c'est important et je voudrais
pas non plus sur la loi de programmation
de formation pour les collectifs locales
que vous avez évoqué où je suis tout à
fait d'accord voilà c'est un peu de tes
réflexions que je voulais faire mais
merci
si monsieur le rapporteur spécial j'ai
donc 16 inscrits
je vais donc alors on est bien clair
qu'on est au tout début au tout début
d'une réflexion c'est pas des sujets qui
se traitent en une séance etc donc nous
avons aujourd'hui ce rapport nous aurons
bien sûr à y revenir par la suite avec
des associations d'élus d'abord et puis
entre nous également avant
éventuellement d'avancer sur ce sujet ne
fut-ce que dans le cas de la mission
dont je parlais dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
je vais vous demander de à chacun de
bien vouloir respecter le cadre
de deux minutes par intervention qui
nous permettrait à peu près de de
laisser le temps de la réponse à nos
invités bien entendu donc je démarre
tout de suite avec Michel canvett puis
Thierry Cosic merci monsieur le
président à la page 42 de l'excellent
rapport de la Cour on évoque l'évolution
des ratios d'autonomie financière de
2003-2020 moi j'ai plutôt le sentiment
que ceci diminue d'une part parce que le
pouvoir de décision des assemblées
délibérantes s'atténue et puis aussi
parce que le rapport au local et au
territoire se délite un tout petit peu
et ça il faut le regretter parce qu'il
est nécessaire de retrouver de la
responsabilité des élus et un réel
rapport au territoire dans le
financement des collectivités
territoriales alors ma question porte
sur la CVAE monsieur le Premier
Président puisque la décision n'est
encore pas prise quant à sa suppression
est-ce que celle-ci vous semble
opportune première question la 2
secondes est-ce que l'hypothèse de la
remplacer par la TVA vous semble la
meilleure solution aussi pour les
collectivités territoriales et à défaut
auriez-vous d'autres suggestions à
formuler comme par exemple le téléphone
peut-être
merci Michel Thierry Cosic puis Isabelle
briquet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président je
vous remercie ces premières pistes de de
d'évolution vous le dites le système est
aujourd'hui
à bout de souffle il est complexe je
crois que autour de la table on
s'accorde tous
elle pensait vous avez envisagé un
certain nombre de scénarios moi ma
question était
la suivante on est aujourd'hui en a le
gouvernement qui est une volonté
d'entrer dans une relation
transactionnelle avec les collectivités
territoriales voire même dans
personnaliser les relations avec l'État
notamment le ministre de l'Économie a
été très clair le 14 septembre dernier
en indiquant qu'il y a des collectivités
qui sont bien gérées et d'autres qui
pourront ne pas se prévaloir de l'aide
de l'État donc par le PLF qui arrive le
gouvernement accélère la mise sous
tutelle budgétaire des collectivités
territoriales les obligeants
de pouvoir négocier à l'avenir chaque
ligne budgétaire donc dans les scénarios
de financement que vous vous présentez
il y a des évolutions qui me paraissent
pertinentes ma question serait plutôt la
suivante est-ce que aujourd'hui au
regard des propos que qu'indique le
ministre de l'Économie est-ce qu'il y a
pas un scénario un scénario
alternatif un peu plus un peu plus
globale peut-être plus innovant qui sur
lequel vous auriez pu
évoluer et proposer est-ce qu'il est pas
temps de d'engager une réflexion sur sur
une réforme globale du financement des
collectivités locales
merci Thierry Isabelle briquet puis
Antoine Lefebvre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président je m'associe au
remerciements qui ont été fait
précédemment pour
la conduite de ce de ce rapport mais ma
question porte sur la 4e recommandation
quand je vois c'est plutôt une
interrogation refonte progressivement
les critères de répartition des impôts
nationaux partagés pour mieux tenir
compte des charges des collectivités
évaluées sur la base de critères sociaux
économiques est-ce à dire qu'il serait
estimé à priori les charges d'une
collectivité pour lui attribuer un
nouveau un niveau de ressource donc elle
dont elle aurait besoin le nouveau de
ressources qu'elle aurait besoin pour
les assumer bien que ce ne soit pas le
seul mode de financement cela me semble
tout de même quelque peu remettre en
cause le principe de libre
administration des des collectivités en
limitant leur perspective de
de développement en figeant leur
possibilité financière mais j'ai
peut-être mal interprété c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais avoir quelques heures les
éclaircissements à ce sujet sur cette
recommandation là merci merci Isabelle
Antoine Lefebvre puis Jean-François
monsieur le Premier Président mais chers
collègues avec l'objectif zan qui a été
introduit dans la loi climat et
résilience les frères sont posés de plus
en plus pour
gêner les implantations de nos activités
tous les équipements publics qui avaient
nécessairement qui vont forcément en
remettre en question le panier des
recettes fiscales qui étaient perçues
par les communes et qui vont exiger de
revoir complètement le schéma de
fiscalité locale ma question est donc la
suivante sans ces VAE sans taxe
d'habitation et sans perspective
d'extension ou développement
économique des territoires comment faire
perdurer véritablement les l'idée de ce
lien de légitimité locale qui doit
exister entre les contribuables et leur
collectivité et surtout comment ne pas
rendre complètement dépendant et
exemples
les collectivités face à l'Etat comment
assurer une meilleure prévisibilité en
fait des dépenses et des recettes des
collectivités peut-on prévoir d'ailleurs
un certain nombre d'indicateurs qui
seraient fournis aux collectivités pour
les accompagner dans dans ce schéma
prévisionnel merci
[Musique]
il y a une nécessité parce que moi-même
ayant eu en gestion une une commune
pendant de nombreuses années
[Musique]
du littoral et on s'accorde à beaucoup
d'élus du littoral à le dire aujourd'hui
la taxe d'habitation sur la résidence
secondaire n'aura d'efficacité pour les
collectivités locales que si on la délit
de la taxe foncière donc il y a il y a
un élément important de de correcteurs
modificateurs d'indices qui aujourd'hui
lit la taxe d'habitation à la taxe
foncière et ça nécessite forcément de
délier les deux pour donner un peu d'air
à cette taxe d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires et donc aux
collectivités locales ce que je dis je
le fais en portant la voix de nombreux
de nombreux élus en dernier point
finalement vous avez parlé du Comité des
finances locales dont j'ai été membre
longtemps d'ailleurs avec avec le
général Charles gainer qui est qui est
qui est présent ici
il sait pourquoi je l'appelle le général
et donc
on c'est vrai que la spécialisation de
l'impôt au niveau du Comité des finances
locales et une grosse fierté est un gros
mot mais finalement au travers votre
rapport et on lit dans dans le les
éléments importants qui sont portés
surtout sur les sur les redevances que
la spécialisation de l'impôt en tant que
tel et au travers des redevances n'est
peut-être pas forcément un gros mot et
pourrait permettre d'avoir une
visibilité beaucoup plus forte et c'est
ce que j'ai compris dans votre rapport
que vous recherchiez une visibilité
forte d'utilisation des finances
publiques donc voilà deux remarques et
puis finalement une préconisation une
question sur la façon dont on pourrait
délier la taxe d'habitation et la taxe
foncière pour donner de l'air à la taxe
d'habitation dans les résidences
secondaires
merci Jean-François Didier Rambaud puis
Stéphane Sautarel merci président une
remarque et une question la remarque je
reprends volontiers la phrase
prononcée par Claude Raynal en
introduction c'est très compliqué
d'ouvrir le débat effectivement alors ma
remarque c'est finalement est-ce que on
ne prend pas le problème à l'envers
parce qu'avant de parler de financement
des collectivités locales peut-être de
savoir quel collectivités locales
voulons-nous depuis 20-30 ans on tourne
en rond parce que effectivement les
collectivités locales c'est comme les
niches fiscales derrière chaque
collectivité il y a il y a un lobby qui
est en marche durant la campagne
présidentielle il y a eu en matière
décentralisation une proposition
concrète qui est celle de la création du
conseiller territorial bon personne sait
on va aller jusqu'au bout mais je pense
qu'elle va peut-être être cette
proposition si elle se confirme
permettrait peut-être de décanter un
petit peu la la situation il suffira de
trouver le mode d'élection du
conseillerais si c'est sur une base
département
et donc départementale ou sur une liste
régionale et base régionale et à partir
de là je pense que la la question de la
des répartitions d'impôts entre
collectivités ce sera beaucoup plus
facile à le faire sinon une question au
premier président donc parmi les
scénarios qu'il a qu'il a présenté qu'il
serait sur lui le scénario le plus
efficace pour pour tenir la trajectoire
des rétablissements des finances
publiques parce que je pense qu'il faut
aussi toujours avoir cela en perspective
merci
merci Didier Stéphane sottarel puis
Hervé Moret
oui merci monsieur le Premier Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général sur le rapporteur
spécial tout d'abord moi je voulais vous
remercier pour l'éclairage que vous
apportez sans sans rentrer aujourd'hui
comme vous nous avions encouragé
monsieur le Président dans dans un débat
qui nous amènerait plus avant sur sur
des choix ou des orientations mais je
pense que le le la proposition en tout
cas les pistes les scénarios qui qui
sont avancés en réponse à un diagnostic
partagé de système à bout de sous de
constat d'absolescence de sédimentation
au fût au fur de fur et à mesure de de
l'histoire de ces financement de nos
collectivités nous amènent à souhaiter
cette réforme systémique ce nouveau
modèle que que vous êtes sur lequel vous
nous apportez des éléments des éléments
précieux avec des options qui me
semblent effectivement présenté un cadre
de référence avec l'objectif que vous
rappelez d'ailleurs dans votre
introduction de l'autonomie financière
qui est le premier principe de libre
administration de nos collectivités
territoriales qui est absolument qui est
absolument essentielle moi je voulais
attirer
votre attention sur sur deux points
autour de la territorialisation bien sûr
beaucoup y ont insisté et elle est
essentielle mais aussi des corrections
des inégalités de notre système de
péréquation qui doit aller de pair avec
cette territorialisation et de même la
question de la prise en compte de la
réalité des charges même si c'est un
élément nouveau et sur lequel comme
Charles gainer l'a rappelé il y a un
travail incontestablement à faire bien
évidemment en veillant à ce qu'on ne
soit pas dans un cadre de tutelle mais
me semble être une piste essentielle à
travailler si on veut réellement
s'interroger sur sur notre sur notre
modèle en soulignant aussi ou en
rappelant ce que vous avez bien montré
dans votre rapport avec les exemples
européens la relative faiblesse de la
dépense publique locale dans notre dans
notre pays sur laquelle on pourrait
s'interroger et là effectivement ça peut
relier la question du financement avec
l'exercice des compétences
juste une question sur un point qui
concerne le pacte de confiance qui me
semble être un élément assez essentiel
auquel je crois à titre à titre
personnel mais mais qui doit être un
pacte c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui est
contractualisé qui est partagé et qui
n'est pas imposé et qui doit être de
confiance c'est-à-dire aussi s'inscrire
dans la durabilité dans la lisibilité et
dans la libre administration de chacun
donc qui renvoie aussi aux outils de
gouvernance que vous proposiez et ça me
semble être un sujet essentiel si on
veut avancer sur une réforme qui est
forcément difficile mais qui doit donner
des garanties dans la durée de
lisibilité pour nos concitoyens mais
aussi pour nos collectivités je vous
remercie
merci Stéphane Hervé Moret puis
Christian Millac merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Vice-Président je voudrais
tout d'abord dire qu'à mon sens il faut
être prudent quand on parle de la
situation financière des collectivités
locales parce que c'est une et vous le
savez mieux que moi c'est une catégorie
très hétérogène c'est comme quand on
parle du revenu agricole donc quand on
dit que la situation des collectivités
locales s'est améliorée c'est
certainement vrai je ne l'ai pas en
doute vos constats mais ça couvre des
diversités considérables entre des
départements d'Île-de-France et des
petites communes qui ont vu baisser leur
dotation au fil des années qui parfois
soit obligé de renoncer aux indemnités
des élus pour pour équilibrer le budget
je le dis parce que en ce moment c'est
l'argument cet argument est souvent
évoqué pour ne pas faire les efforts
nécessaires de la part de l'État par
rapport au choc de l'inflation ensuite
dans la présentation de vos trois
options de financement
vous dites que les financements des
impôts nationaux sont plus prév
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquiez en
quoi et même chose sur la possibilité de
renforcer les dotations tout en
respectant le principe d'autonomie pour
moi c'est un petit peu antinomique
ensuite je reste un petit peu au terme
de présentation sur ma faim quant aux
critères que vous envisageriez pour
répartir les impôts nationaux je peux
imaginer que pour les départements ce
serait éventuellement les dépenses
sociales en revanche pour pour les
régions ou même pour les communes quels
seraient les critères que vous
envisageriez et enfin je reste
totalement sur ma faim mais peut-être
que ça aurait nécessité et que ça
nécessiterait un rapport en soi sur la
DGF dont vous parlez très peu et qui est
quelque chose de totalement opaque
personne aujourd'hui aucun maire au
qu'un élu ne sait pourquoi ça déggef et
de tel montant et quand vous interrogez
la DGCL et Sami ça m'est arrivé quand
j'étais mère on n'a jamais de réponse je
crois qu'elle a DGCL très peu de gens
sont en capacité de répondre il y a un
vrai sujet sur ce calcul de DGF sur ça
son opacité et je crois que ce serait
important qu'on puisse avancer là-dessus
je ne parle même pas de la différence de
DGF selon qu'on est commune rurale ou
commune urbaine
merci Hervé Christian BIAC puis Vincent
Delahaye
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Premier Président merci
aussi pour ce rapport je vous rejoins
monsieur le Président quand vous avez
dit qu'il fallait cesser les
rafistolages de dernière minute il y a
trop longtemps que de la boîte à
pharmacie ne sort que les sparadra
des pansements et autres bandelettes et
ferait quand même de soigner le malade
de manière un peu plus pérenne
vous avez souligné monsieur le Premier
Président de la bonne santé les
collectivités effectivement c'est
globalement c'est une bonne santé
contrairement à l'étape puisque un
accident c'est un gros mot pour le
budget de l'État excédent c'est toujours
déficit là les collectivités globalement
4 milliards d'excédents
je vais être répondre
les principes l'équilibre avait la
prévisibilité à la soutenabilité la
stérilone des impôts locaux et la
solidarité moi la question que je vous
pose concernant le bloc communal dans
l'essentiel des ressources concernent
l'impôt local c'est comment on considère
la territorialisation de l'impôt et la
solidarité parce que qui dit
terridoranisation nous dit potentielle
fiscal dont des richesses de la commune
et donc comment on va concilier en
sachant qu'il y a de grandes inégalités
entre les communes en France et que une
péréquation nécessaire alors est-ce que
ça fera par le biais de la DSR de la DFU
par le fond de préquation intercommunale
ou communale voilà comment on va
concilier cette territorisation et en
même temps cette solidarité
Charles Guénet il est rabots ont évoqué
les charges réelles
le problème est de savoir ce que sont
les charges réel est trop souvent on
confond les charges réelles et les
charges constatées
elles ne sont que la conséquence de la
richesse parce que une commune riche
peut avoir des charges parce qu'elle a
les moyens de les payer une commune de
pauvre elle l'a pas elle voudrait bien
mais comme le chantier une chanteuse
elle peut point et donc elle voudrait
bien dépenser mais comme elle a pas les
ressources et dans les charges réel
c'est pas forcément les charges constaté
et on compare souvent ces deux choses je
conclurai en disant que je regrette
quand même même si l'impôt local reste
essentiel que l'impôt universel qui
était la TH est disparu bon c'est comme
ça
aujourd'hui on est on a plus toutes les
tranche de population qui paye l'impôt
et moi je crois que l'impôt c'est son
universalité qui fait sa valeur qu'il
s'agit de l'impôt sur le revenu la taxe
d'habitation quand tout le monde paye et
bien on a les contribuables de lien
direct entre l'administration entre le
politique et le citoyen qu'on perd quand
l'impôt n'est plus payé par tout le
monde et ensuite sur la CVAE donc moi je
veux bien mais est-ce qu'on envisagea
quand même une taxe sur les nuisances
parce que l'activité économique c'est
souvent aussi des nuisances qui si elles
sont compensées par des ressources sont
supportées mais lorsqu'il y a des
nuisances sans contrepartie et bien les
élus locaux et la population tente à
rejeter et on voit ici ou là certaines
prises de production déjà depuis que
l'impôt économique a été transféré à
l'interco ou des communes qui
supportaient la carrière malgré les
pétards et la poussière ne la supporte
plus depuis que l'impôt par parcours au
lieu de rester dans la commune voilà les
quelques remarques que je voulais faire
et quelques questions
merci Christian Vincent Delahaye puis
Eric Bocquet oui merci monsieur le
Président c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
compliqué les finances locales et que
c'est un sujet sur lequel à mon avis il
faut pas partir en cherchant
immédiatement le consensus mais il faut
plutôt chercher de la clarté de
l'efficacité et ne pas hésiter à mettre
les pieds dans le plat si on veut
pouvoir avancer
parce que si on cherche le consensus
systématiquement on avancera pas alors
depuis quelques années on assiste
finalement à la suppression de taxes
locales c'est son plus facile de
supprimer des taxes locales que des
taxes nationales et que cette
suppression entraîne deux conséquences
néfastes c'est d'abord de couper un
certain nombre de citoyens de la dépense
locale et de la vie locale puisqu'ils
sont plus contributeurs et puis la
deuxième c'est de rendre les
collectivités de plus en plus dépendants
de l'État donc ça c'est ces deux écueils
qu'à mon avis faudrait réussir quand
même à inverser et dans cette deuxième
partie de la dépendance vis-à-vis de
l'État moi je suis aussi comme Hervé
Moret restez un peu sur enfin par
rapport à ce que vous appelez
rationalisation des dotations alors je
sais pas si c'est le si c'est la réforme
des dotations mais c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui
à force d'avoir changé les les
références d'un certain nombre de
dotation on a un système qui n'est plus
du tout compréhensible et qui varie
alors parfois de choses négatives mais
de 0 à 800 euros par habitant c'est
incompréhensible sur le plan local dans
mon département moi je fais un bilan
annuel et effectivement je j'arrive pas
à voir d'explication donc est-ce que
est-ce que vous êtes partisan d'une
réforme de ces dotations
merci Vincent Eric Bocquet puis Vanina
Paoli
merci monsieur le Président j'ai
toujours souligné la qualité des
rapports de la Cour des comptes mais
parfois je ne partage pas les
recommandations les il y a quelques
irritants qui nous amènent à réagir mais
la qualité des rapports est là et ce
rapport vraiment est intéressant et
utile et tombe à point nommé à un moment
où tous les élus s'interrogent pour
savoir comment ils vont boucler l'année
pour savoir s'ils vont installer des
décorations de Noël pour savoir de quel
excédent ils vont disposer en 2023 pour
faire de l'investissement donc vraiment
il y a matière à donner de la visibilité
à l'ensemble des élus parce que les
questionnements sont exprimés vous le
savez bien dans les assemblées générales
en ce moment dans tous les congrès
départementaux des mers les mers ruraux
de partout ça monte
alors
voilà le premier point que je voulais
aborder ensuite une question que je
partage avec Hervé Moret sur vous dites
monsieur le Premier Président que le les
impôts nationaux auraient l'avantage de
délai davantage de visibilité aux
cellules locaux je partage pas trop en
voulant je comprends pas très bien au
contraire parce que sur les impôts que
les collectivités ne maîtrisent pas qui
sont sujets avariation en fonction des
crises Kris covid crise énergétique du
moment
récession économique etc donc je vois
pas très bien en quoi ça ça constitue un
gage de visibilité le recours aux impôts
nationaux partagés je me félicite que
vous reteniez dans les trois options
polaires le maintien des dotations
d'État renforcés de manière à garantir
l'autonomie fiscale et financière des
communes c'est bien que ce point ne soit
pas évacué éliminé d'emblée dans vos
réflexions je trouve ça très positif
deuxième point que je voulais évoquer je
me félicite également que le vous
fassiez figurer la page 27 le tableau
comparatif des six pays de l'Union
européenne que sont la France
l'Allemagne l'Espagne le communit la
Pologne et l'Italie et qui montre que la
France n'est pas celle qui dépense le
plus en euros par habitant par ses
collectivités et quand on connaît
l'importance des collectivités dans les
mises en place des services publics
locaux l'investissement public est
encore supérieur à 70 %, c'est bien de
le rappeler parce qu'on entend cette
petite musique régulièrement des
collectivités obèses dispendieux etc
coûteuse ce tableau remet les choses un
peu en place et dernière chose que je
voulais dire je suggère que ce rapport
soit envoyé à Monsieur le Ministre des
comptes publics Gabriel Attal
pour qu'il en prenne connaissance et
suscite sa réflexion je vais dire un
extrait d'une interview qu'il a donné à
la Gazette la semaine dernière c'est pas
très long je vais me permettre de citer
à propos de la maîtrise des dépenses des
collectivités il dit ceci il faut qu'il
y ait un cadre qui s'installe pour que
si jamais des collectivités et des
strates ne font pas l'effort de maîtrise
de la hausse leur dépense de
fonctionnement ils puissent y avoir une
incitation jusque là ça va la première
année ce sera l'absence d'accès à toute
dotation de l'État
dsil la dotation de soutien
l'investissement local DETR fond vert
pour les collectivités n'ayant pas
respecté l'objectif au sein d'une
catégorie qui ne l'a pas atteint non
plus ensuite six manifestement il n'y a
pas vraiment de volonté de s'inscrire
dans cette trajectoire alors que les
autres collectivités le font ils
pourraient y avoir des reprises mais je
ne me place pas dans cette optique là
tout ça est dit dans un langage très
persien incitation
reprise non accès à des dotations c'est
quand même une forme de mise sous
tutelle direct une collectivité donc je
suggère que ce rapport soit envoyé à
Monsieur le Ministre dès que possible si
c'est possible d'ailleurs merci
merci
Eric Vanina paoligajen
Président
Monsieur le Premier Président merci pour
ce travail de rapport qui
suscite trois interrogations sur la
solidarité d'abord je n'ai pas vu ce
erreur de ma part mention du pic j'avais
envie de comprendre si vous estimez que
ce dispositif qui ne devait pas être
pérenne doivent être réévaluées
notamment dans ses clés de répartition
pour ma part dans mon département
80% des flux vont à la métropole et il y
a un certain nombre de communes rurales
qui s'interrogent sur la justice entre
guillemets fiscale au regard de cette
clé de répartition
vous
dans un de vos scénaris je crois vous
vous préconisez un retour de la
fiscalité de l'énergie à l'état
est-ce que ça couvre l'hifère parce que
si c'est le cas avec l'accélération du
déploiement des projets onérait ENR sur
les territoires et les problèmes
croissants aussi d'acceptabilité des
projets je doute que s'il n'y a pas de
retour pécunier sous forme fiscale au
territoire concernés et aux habitants de
ces territoires qui subissent une
certaine manière une partie des
externalités négatives de ces projets ce
soit un peu difficile et enfin je
m'interroge sur la la piste de solutions
en termes de gouvernance
pas d'autres remèdes dans notre pays
pour tous les mots que nous avons que de
créer de nouvelles structures puisque et
préconiser la création d'une
autorisation d'une autorité pardon
administrative indépendante sans
suppression corrélative enfin j'ai pas
vu des organismes qui existent d'ores et
déjà merci beaucoup
merci Vanina Victorin Lurel puis
Jean-Baptiste blanc merci monsieur le
Président j'aimerais pour ma part
féliciter la commission des finances nos
présidents et rapporteur pour avoir
demandé cet accident rapport et bien
entendu le travail de la Cour des
comptes et de ces sections
le président a évoqué la situation
apparemment fort favorable des
collectivités mais des collègues qui
m'ont précédé l'ont déjà dit bon il y a
de vraies différences il y a des strates
différentes et il y a des communes
pauvres et des communes qui ont des
devraient difficultés à mon sens une
petite différenciation c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas l'avantage d'avoir lu le
rapport lui-même mais j'ai lu la
synthèse et ça me paraît nécessaire de
faire la distinction les communes qui
ont et des collectivités en général qui
ont de vraies difficultés un regret
c'est que il n'y ait pas vous l'écorce
et outre-mer la situation est
différentes et après le rapport patient
et Cazeneuve je crois que ça mérite une
réactualisation et je demanderai à nos
présidents et rapporteurs de demander le
même type de rapport pour les autres
mais et la Corse sur les
[Musique]
scénarios le premier scénario
qui apparemment aurait la préférence de
la course et le sentiment que je retire
de cette lecture puisque ce serait
équilibré il n'y aurait pas de perdant
ni de gagnants et qui aurait une
rationalisation des notations ça
mériterait d'être précisé
vous appuyez sur ce que prépare l'état
la suppression de la CVAE
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres possibilités
notamment une possible suppression de la
citoise S est-ce que on peut faire ça
d'ailleurs c'est une demande faite il me
semble par l'Association des maires de
France et qui aurait le bénéfice de
il me semble de mieux préserver les
communes est-ce que ça peut entrer dans
cette simulation là peut-être pour
encore
améliorer son rendu sur le deuxième
scénario
est-ce que vous intégrez j'ai entendu ça
la
DGF et pourquoi pour les départements
peut-être que la réponse figure dans le
rapport lui-même mais pourquoi
limiter à 63%
la dotation d'action sociale est-ce
qu'il y a là une raison
mathématique ou statistiques qui
justifierait
cette ce ratio là ce taux là je connais
certaines collectivités qui restent à
charge considérable et que soutenance
satisfait à cette objective
d'équilibre sur le troisième scénario
j'avoue que je ne le comprends pas
puisque il y a la un triple équilibre à
préserver d'un triple objectif pas
préserver l'équilibre la
territorialisation et la solidarité je
crois pas que très bien comment
goupiller ça peut-être que c'est dans le
rapport mais si vous avez quelques mots
de clarification j'en serais forte en
fait sur la gouvernance
certains ici et ailleurs ont évoqué une
possible loi de financement des
collectivités là vous proposez soit une
autorité indépendante soit un
renforcement
du Comité des finances locales est-ce
inactuelle
inefficace d'avoir ou de penser ou de
réfléchir même si ça demande au
préalable peut-être une réforme
constitutionnelle qui est une loi de
financement avec cette possibilité de
dialogue
de permanence des rapports entre l'État
entre le central et le local est-ce que
c'est possible voilà donc très
rapidement
merci Victorin Jean-Baptiste plan et
Bernard delcro s'il y a pas d'autres
demandes concurrents les questions
merci monsieur le Président je voulais à
mon tour c'est lui la qualité de ce
travail et notamment les trois options
dites polaires qui sont mis sur la table
je voulais poser une question de
climatisation
dans la foulée puisque se pose aussi le
rapport l'évoque la question des
financements de la transition écologique
et probablement de sa fiscalité par
transition écologique j'entends le
financement du 0 artificialisation net
évoquée par certains collègues aussi
donc
à ce titre on attend notre rapport dans
les prochains jours celui du Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires on attend
ardemment parce que c'est cette question
est très sensible dans tous les
territoires celle du financement du zan
et probablement de la fiscalité d'usage
qui appellera de notre part un grand
effort d'imagination fiscale
merci Jean-Baptiste Bernard n'aura pas
finalement la chance de conclure c'est
Marc laminy qui l'aura donc Bernard
delcro très vite merci Michel président
merci pour ce pour ce rapport je
voudrais
tout d'abord
rappeler comme l'ont fait d'ailleurs
Hervé Moret et
Eric Bocquet je crois vous avez rappelé
dans le début de votre intervention la
situation financière favorable en sortie
de crise des collectivités avec un
accident de 4,7 milliards la note de
Bercy l'indiquait aussi il faut bien
faire attention de pas laisser penser
que la situation toutes les
collectivités est très bonne et derrière
cette moyenne se cache comme ça a été
rappelé par un certain nombre de
collègues évidemment des disparités très
très importantes et un certain nombre de
collectivités notamment les plus petites
se trouve en situation de difficulté
pour faire face notamment à
l'augmentation des prix donc je veux le
rappeler parce que voilà il faut pas que
cette
ce constat qui réel bien sûr on n'est
pas ça laisse à penser que toutes les
collectivités vont bien alors vous avez
souvent dans votre rapport utilisé les
mots de visibilité de prévisibilité de
solidarité je pense qu'effectivement ce
sont ces mots là qui doivent guider la
réforme et de l'autonomie financière
aussi alors j'ai deux de trois questions
sur la solidarité vous avez indiqué vous
avez dit exactement je pense la
péréquation manque d'objectifs clairs et
la péréquation horizontale et largement
insuffisante vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus quel est votre vision sur
le sur le sujet sur la question dans vos
propositions des recettes des
départements et des régions vous avez
dit il faut diversifier on prévoit
diversifier le panier de recettes et
donc faire appel à plusieurs impôts
nationaux là où aujourd'hui il y en a
qu'un à travers la TVA donc notamment
l'IS pour les régions et lierre pour les
départements
je voudrais bien comprendre l'intérêt de
faire appel à plusieurs impôts nationaux
plutôt qu'à
un seul
et enfin sur je rejoins ce qui a été dit
aussi sur la part d'impôts national moi
je suis pas opposé d'ailleurs à titre
personnel à une part d'impro national
parce que je trouve ça aussi un effet
péréquateur mais en revanche je vois pas
pourquoi l'impôt national aurait une
prévisibilité de recettes pour les
collectivités qui seraient meilleure
qu'un impôt qu'un impôt local donc voilà
si vous pouvez nous apporter quelques
explications sur ce sujet ce serait bien
merci merci Bernard et donc Marc Lamini
pour conclure cette fois oui très
rapidement merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Premier Président de
la Cour des comptes et l'ensemble
je dirais
de tout c'est les ceux qui ont travaillé
beaucoup sur ces dossiers partagés avec
nos deux rapporteurs spéciaux Claude
Reynal et Charles Guénet merci pour ces
documents de synthèse alors concernant
le vous intitulé bloc communal mais
c'est vrai que
communal et intercommunal et on
s'aperçoit que je dirais on reste
attaché beaucoup les Chelon de base que
sont les communes et y compris les
petites communes et c'est vrai que les
intercommunalités ont pris quand même
beaucoup de de compétences de plus en
plus renforcée et
concernant
les les
dotations c'est vrai que l'État reste le
premier partenaire financier des
collectivités territoriales bloque les
départements et les régions et c'est
vrai que d'une collectivité à l'autre et
les départements malheureusement
investissent beaucoup de moins en moins
est-ce qu'on pourrait trouver des
solutions à ce niveau là puisque je
dirais le poids du social et réellement
important pour cette les collectivités
départementales
la création d'une autorité indépendante
alors ma question modeste certes mais
je dirais il y a des gens beaucoup de
travail qui est fait à l'échelle des
deux commissions des finances des deux
assemblées et aussi tout le travail de
la Cour des comptes toutes les
institutions qui qui interviennent les
associations d'élus
vous parlez beaucoup de simplification
mais si une autorité indépendante en
plus ça fait encore une un interlocuteur
en plus
donc en termes de lisibilité et
concernant
l'ensemble des dotations fonctionnement
et investissement bon le but c'est que
les collectivités puissent investir je
crois que c'est aussi le et vous n'avez
pas évoqué le dispositif France relance
qui tient aussi une place prépondérante
qu'en est-il et aussi sur son devenir je
vous remercie
merci Marc
nous allons donner une grosse demi-heure
à la cour pour
17 interventions à peu près 35 questions
voilà monsieur le Premier Président si
ça vous convient je prendrai un petit
quart d'heure peut-être
je dis ça pourquoi parce que
attention les interventions je les
prends autant comme des questions qui
nous sont adressées que comme je demande
un premier round de débat entre vous à
partir de notre rapport et donc je me
permettrai de pas répondre à tout parce
que d'abord ça de réponse qui sont en
rapport elle-même et ensuite il y a un
certain nombre de choses sur lequel je
ne souhaite pas improviser parce que
nous fondons en général sur des analyses
je dirais simplement que nous restons
disponible pour d'autres travaux avec
vous et c'est peut-être pas là que je
voulais commencer par vous remercier de
vous remerciements
vous avez dit au début de votre
intervention monsieur le Président que
c'était un sujet impossible il l'est il
l'est parce qu'il est très complexe il
est parce qu'il divise il est parce que
comme vous l'avez dit toucher à quelque
chose sur ces sujets immédiatement fait
bouger toute une série de forces qui
jouent dans d'autres sens et ça rend
très compliqué en effet
réforme nous en sommes conscients mais
ce que je voulais vous dire je voulais
l'ajouter parce que je le sais moi je
suis le premier président de la Cour des
comptes ce sont les équipes qui
travaillent je sais que tous ceux qui
ont travaillé sur ce sujet à la Cour
sont très heureux d'avoir essayé
ont été passionnées par le sujet et que
ce rapport nous voyons modestement comme
une contribution pour éclairer le débat
votre débat et là je le dis aussi aux
rapporteur général oui les mots vous est
prononcé dialogue échangent partage son
fondamentaux et les propositions que
nous avons faites sur la gouvernance ou
les avez évoqué toutes les deux sont à
nos yeux absolument essentiels la
méthode et le fond en vérité
ce sujet sont tellement étroitement
imbriqués qu'on peut pas avancer sur là
sans avoir progressé sur l'autre et ça
me paraît tout à fait décisif dans la
situation où nous sommes
j'ajoute enfin pour terminer ses propos
d'introduction générale que nous restons
à votre disponibilité disposition vous
avez évoqué la méthode que vous
souhaitiez utiliser à partir du rapport
pour dialoguer avec d'autres si vous
souhaitez nous y associer d'une façon ou
d'une autre je pense que nous n'y seront
pas hostile ce rapport il se défend pas
seulement aujourd'hui pas seulement
pendant sa publication mais on peut
ouvrir aussi un petit peu nos cuisines
pour dire ce qu'il y a derrière tel ou
telle option telle ou telle hypothèse
telle ou telle scénario
voilà pour qu'elle est bien le sens de
mon intervention et expliquer pourquoi
finalement elle sera plus brève qu'elle
pourrait être une réponse méticuleuse
associée ou cela ce qui ne m'empêchera
pas quand même de dire à certaines de
choses monsieur le Président d'abord
plusieurs d'entre vous
ont ticket je crois qu'on peut dire ça
vous souligner si on ne veut pas prendre
de connotation péjorative le fait que le
rapport insisterait sur une situation
financière favorable et collectivités en
soulignant tout de suite que c'était
trop général bien sûr la cour publiera
d'ici fin octobre son rapport sur la
situation financière de collectivités en
2022 et les perspectives après suite
juillet sur les contes 2021 ce que nous
savons c'est que le retour de
l'inflation pèse sur les achats des
collectivités que la hausse du point des
fonctionnaires décidé pour maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat modifie le contexte mais
que les ressources fiscales notamment
les taxes foncières pour le blocage sont
dynamiques alors que le poids de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie elle est
dans terre apparaît plus faible dans les
dépenses de fonctionnement des
départements et des régions en outre le
gouvernement a adapté ces mesures de
soutien dans la LFR 2022 donc nous
savons bien que ce que j'ai dit sur le
contexte favorable d'abord sera
relativisé en 20 par rapport à 2021 et
je l'ai souligné dans mon propos
introductif il faudra être attentif aux
évolutions du contexte macroéconomique
aux situations individuelles mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a un niveau inédit de
l'épargne brut des collectivités en 2021
de 41,4 milliards d'euros qui dépasse le
précédent record de 2019 39 milliards
d'euros ce qui permet d'être confiant
sur la situation globale des politiques
et locales je le dis en cours n'ignore
en rien bien sûr
l'hétérogénéité des situations voire les
inégalités qui peuvent exister
j'ai senti dans les propos du rapporteur
général
n'ont pas une suspicion mais une
interrogation sur ce que la Cour pouvait
penser par rapport au tmto au
département
au fond je pourrais résumer la question
qui la vôtre pourquoi nationaliser les
DMTO et retire au département leur
Solveig fiscal c'est de la réponse que
nous a faites l'Association des
départements de France j'ai dit que
trois raisons justifiées cette
orientation qui était proposée également
par rapport sur et Richard en 2018 c'est
une ressource très volatile difficile à
prévoir
c'est une assiette inégalement répartie
entre les territoires et ça ne donne pas
aujourd'hui un vrai levier local car si
l'assiette était territorisée le taux
est déjà quasiment uniforme j'ajoute que
l'affectation des DMT au bloc communal
permettrait d'affecter à ce niveau toute
la fiscalité locale liée au foncier en
cohérence avec une mission de cette
échelon une répartition progressive en
fonction du critère socio-économique des
territoires permettrait de réduire à la
base des inégalités renforcerait la
solidarité du système donc non non
nous pensons que les départements ont un
rôle majeur à jouer la cour propose de
mettre en place un financement plus
équitable et pérenne des départements
avec un partage d'impôts nationaux une
dotation dynamique d'action sociale qui
suit les dépenses sociales
cercle Sénat représenté le rapport
retire au département une recette
iniquitablement répartie et très
volatile incertaine mais en échange les
impôts partagés sont dynamiques et la
dotation avec le social garantir au
moins 63% des dépenses sociales
constatées dans chaque département bon
mais je dis ça juste pour expliquer ce
qui a été notre option évidemment pas
voulu privilégier une strat de
collectivité au détriment d'une autre
nous incitons suffisamment dans nos
analyses sur les politiques sociales sur
le rôle des départements et sur y
compris les besoins auxquels ils font
face pour être tout à fait conscient de
ça je voulais simplement rappeler ce qui
était la mécanique elle est discutable
elle est à votre disposition
et là ce mérite là
j'ai été interrogé je suis pas monsieur
le rapporteur spécial oui il y a des
choses qui qui manquent dans ce rapport
naturellement il y a des parties qui ont
été pris des options qui ont été
choisies
sur la refonte des critères de
répartition à n'importe où a été réalisé
grâce à l'émission d'une députée
Christelle piresburn qui n'a plus
aboutir mais qui avait permis d'établir
de façon consensuelle que notre système
actuel est dépassé peu lisible voire
dans certains cas source d'inégalités et
notre proposition je crois soumis à quel
point cette réforme a indispensable pour
allouer presque 30 milliards d'euros de
plus de fiscalité nationale ou
collectifs dans le système actuel il
faut bien définir les critères nous
n'avons pas détaillé le système de
répartition idéale il découle de choix
politiques structurant
qu'il revient à l'exécutif et au
législatif de faire la cour chez maldire
n'est ni un pouvoir ni un contre-pouvoir
éclaire la décision publique par ses
analyses et ses propositions
techniquement la question n'est pas non
plus triviale la cour je vous le dis
monsieur le rapporteur puisque vous avez
quelque sorte lancer cette perche
pourraient approfondir cette question
lors d'un prochain rapport mais ce sujet
est directement dépendant du système de
financement retenu il en découle et ne
le précède pas
vous m'avez aussi interrogé sur les
missions de l'autorité indépendante et
la différence par rapport au Comité des
finances locales toute réforme du
financement des collectivités exigent de
rétablir une confiance le mot est
fondamental
fondé sur un dialogue structuré et sur
un partage des données des analyses la
création d'une autorité indépendante qui
serait donnée de service et de moyens
d'analyses j'ai assisté sur la donnée
dans l'introduction pourrait être une
option ce ne serait pas au Conseil
d'experts comme les le Conseil des
finances publiques ça devrait être
distinct de la cour car l'autorité
organiserait la concentration entre les
représentants des collectivités et
l'État une présidence indépendante
permettrait de faciliter la propriété
des enjeux financiers et des constats à
partager et on pourra envisager
plusieurs missions un rôle de garant des
principes de financement des
collectivités locales un rôle d'avis sur
le texte financier Harol de production
et de commandes d'études et d'analyses à
défaut d'une autorité administrative
indépendante le rapport préconise à
minima une réforme à la fois des
missions au-delà de la DGF qui ne
concerne plus les régions et de la
composition du comité des finances
locales pour qu'il y ait plus
d'indépendance de représenter
différents niveaux de quel type pour
renforcer le dialogue horizontales et
aussi sans doute les moyens d'analyses
voilà les options que nous vous
soumettons
la cour je le précise à travailler dans
ce rapport à cas de compétences inchangé
là aussi vous avez évoqué cette question
parce que c'est un sujet qui est déjà
vaste ambitieux tel quel mais je suis
d'accord qu'il y a une réflexion globale
à avoir sur la décentralisation 40 ans
après le premier acte engagé et c'est
pourquoi je vous le dis ici j'aurais
peut-être l'occasion de revenir cette
occasion j'ai souhaité que la Cour
consacre son rapport publique annuel
je reviendrai début 23 ou bilan
décentralisation 40 ans après en
abordant alors le sujet des compétences
donc nous allons y revenir
je sais aussi que votre assemblée a
relancé la semaine dernière un groupe de
travail sur les décentralisation présidé
par Madame Gatel auquel je crois vous
participez tous les deux monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur général
qui rendra ses conclusions en avril
prochain et là encore peut-être notre
arbre public pourra aider à éclairer vos
propres travaux
alors ensuite j'en viens à diverses
questions encore une fois ce sont les
traités toutes mais nous pourrons
poursuivre ce dialogue
sur la CVAE
je ne sais pas ce que le gouvernement
décidera
il est clair tout de même que l'option a
été prise de supprimer progressivement
la CBE et ça s'inscrit dans une volonté
qui est celle de réduire les impôts de
production
c'est un choix politique sur lequel j'ai
pas me prononcer
ce que j'ai dit en revanche devant vous
il y a quelques semaines je le redis ici
c'est que la cour et j'ajoute très
personnellement j'en suis persuadé
considère que la situation des finances
publiques ne permet pas de poursuivre
les baisses d'impôts sans conversation
par d'autres hausse d'impôts ou par des
baisses de dépenses les baisses d'impôts
sèches ne sont pas dans les moyens du
pays au moment où il fut rétablir la
situation des finances publiques vous
m'avez interrogé sur ce sujet là je vous
renvoie à la fois aux analyses ou
conseils et les finances publiques et
celle de la cour sur les scénarios à
suivre en précisant bien sûr mais vous
l'avez dit les autres que personne ne
peut exonéré de sa part d'efforts à
condition que ce soit la juste part
sur la compensation par la TVA c'est
sans doute la plus simple mais la TVA
qui est le premier impôts de France est
partagé à plus de 50% avec la sécurité
sociale et que le local donc c'est pas
quelque chose sur lequel il y a des
marges de manœuvre considérables
on m'a interrogé sur prévisibilité de
l'impôt national
elle n'est pas parfaite mais les
supérieurs à celle des dotations
la TVA est stable qui a dédié à la
consommation la bourse sur le revenu est
également globalement stable c'est moins
le cas j'en conviens de la posture de
société mais si on se compare aux autres
types de ressources et tout de même
stabilité plus grande c'est pour ça que
nous avons fait cette proposition
je le note préfère supprimer les impôts
des autres que les siens propres
plusieurs d'entre vous ont interrogé en
la matière
et
en contrepartie il compense par des
impôts partagés ne vont pas étudier dans
le détail de dotations sauf à dire que
les dotations de péréquation sont
insuffisamment sélectives mais là aussi
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous pourrons
revenir dans le passé
sur le retour de la fiscalité
énergétique à l'état
ça ne concerne pas l'ifère qui irait au
bloc communal
nous n'avons pas en effet examiner
l'outre-mer et la Corse
car il y a là des ressources très
spécifiques et nous étions déjà dans un
rapport qui nous occupait suffisamment
mais nous pourrions en effet y revenir
encore je rappelle que le 58 2 est fait
pour que vous puissiez nous soumettre un
certain nombre de rapports et nous le
faisons toujours
évoquer la passion que les équipes ont
médias sera pas un très très grand
plaisir
donc je ne sais pas mais ça vous revient
de discuter avec eux votre président
avec le rapporteur général de ce que
vous pourriez nous demander la
suppression de ces 3S elle n'a pas la
même impact sur la compétitivité des
entreprises car la C3S est très
concentrée là je fais appel à ma mémoire
auparavant
sur une loi de finance locale la cour
partage l'objectif d'une vision plus
globale des finances locales constatant
que le Parlement n'a pas une
présentation unique de l'ensemble des
moyens consacrés par l'État aux
politiques territorial elle a résonné à
4 constitutionnelles constants le fait
toujours ce qui ne permet pas de créer
une nouvelle catégorie loi financière
nous interdisons les incursions dans le
domaine et nous sommes conscients en
même temps des enjeux
et donc nous préconisons comme dans
notre rapport de novembre 2020 sur les
gouvernance publique de rassembler dans
une mission budgétaire unique les
crédits de l'actuelle mission relations
avec les territoriale avec les
subventions et ministères les
prélèvements sur Recettes la fille qui
était partagée la réforme organique de
décembre 2021 la cependant pas retenu
cette notion vous le savez et prévu un
rapport sur les finances locales annexé
ou PLF vous aurez pour la première fois
ce rapport examiner avec le péf 2023
mais bon ne veut pas dire qu'on ne peut
pas aller plus loin ce que nous sommes
au bout de l'ambition pas nécessairement
encore une fois c'est le champ du
politique enfin dernière question je
vais lancer un petit quart d'heure à
laquelle je peux répondre peut-être
question Charpy un ou deux sujets
ajoutés
sur les conséquences de la transition
écologique la climatisation ça a été
c'est fondamental dans notre scénario
nous ont proposé de remonter à l'état la
fiscalité écologique aujourd'hui
affectée collectivité
et plus précisément la TICPE affectée
aux régions et départements la taxe sur
les certificats immatriculation avec des
régions la taxe sur la consommation
finale d'électricité bénéficiait en
commun des départements
il est apparu logique à la cour de René
à l'état le pilotage de cette fiscalité
pour l'inscrire dans une politique
globale de transition écologique qui
peut conduire les évolutions dans le
cadre européen ou à des choix motivés
par des enjeux écologiques qui ne
doivent pas impacter les collectivités
lors de notre instruction nous avons par
ailleurs consulté constaté que cette
proposition rejoignait une préoccupation
des régions d'un rendement décroissant
de ces recettes du fait de la fin
annoncée des moteurs thermiques à
l'horizon 2035 qui est vous savez déjà
n'hésitez pas le Parlement pour ce qui
concerne plus précisément le 0
artificiel net des sols le Conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires travaille
activement à vous présenter très
prochainement un diagnostic qui va vous
proposer des pistes pour mettre en
cohérence la fiscalité locale et
subjectif je crois que le rapport va
être adopté très prochainement et la
semaine prochaine
vous présenter très très vite vous
recevrez tout ça dans les tous prochains
jours voilà ce que je pouvais dire en
terminant je voudrais que le ministre
des comptes publics sera bien sûr
destinataire de ce rapport mais que ces
services le connaissent déjà
Christian
merci monsieur le Premier Président
quelques mots complémentaires sur des
questions plus précises qui avait été
posées le taux de 63% que nous avons
retenu en fait c'est parce qu'on voulait
pas affecter le taux d'autonomie
financière des départements aux dalles
qui étaient nécessaires ce qui est
permis par la loi organique donc c'est
pour ça que ce taux est un peu enfin il
nous paraît déjà significatif en termes
de de mon temps deuxième élément
sur la taxe d'habitation sur la
résidence secondaire
la surtaxe elle est possible que dans sa
chambre de situation
on n'a pas étudié dans le détail on
pense néanmoins comme ça on réagissant
rapidement que il faut quand même garder
un certain
encadrement de ce taux majoré pour pas
éviter de peser d'avoir une trop grande
inégalité entre les résidences
secondaires et le reste de la fiscalité
locale mais c'est un sujet qui pourrait
être étudié sur la péréquation le
premier président évoqué c'est vrai nous
sommes assez critique parce que les
montants finalement sont relativement
limités la péréquation verticale celle
que qui va de l'État aux côtés de calci
8,5 milliards d'euros essentiellement
pas la DGF la
péréquation horizontale c'est à peu près
4 milliards d'euros concentré c'est très
fortement sur la DMTO étant d'un
milliard 7 à me souvenir de poisson
qu'on peut faire un peu plus et ne soit
pas convaincus non plus que les deux
dotations solidarité urbaines et poly
territoire ruraux soit suffisamment
sélectif parce que le nombre de
bénéfices communes ici tout à fait
considérable et c'est un sujet sera
notre sens il faut continuer à pouvoir
travailler il y a un dernier point sur
lequel je veux insister c'est sur la
recommandation 4 qui a été évoquée par
plusieurs d'entre vous au fond on dit il
faut répartir les impôts ou les
notations en fonction des besoins des
collectivités alors
on vise pas remettre en cause la libre
administration des côtés de cas chacun
décide comme il se dépenser ce qu'on dit
simplement c'est qu'il faudrait que des
critères socio-éconiques un peu objectif
nombre de jeunes qui les mettent de
route soit vraiment utilisé pleinement
pour que on répartisse ces impôts
partagés ces notations en fonction de
ces critères sociaux économiques
objectifs ensuite il appartient aux
communes et aux régions au département
de de faire comme ils le souhaitent mais
voilà il est pas question de dire il y a
des coûts objectifs
par service public voire respecter les
départements c'est peut-être une
ambition de la direction du budget c'est
pas la nôtre je crois que c'est
l'essentiel ce que je pouvais dire mais
effectivement nous sommes à la
disposition de de la commission des
finances s'ils veulent aller voir sur
certains points que qui n'ont pas été
évoqué aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le Premier Président
merci monsieur le Président merci
à ceux qui ont travaillé avec vous
encore une fois vous avez pu noter que
dans les questions en tout cas il y a eu
de l'intérêt
évidemment pour ce travail
et donc c'est effectivement une phase
maintenant qui s'ouvre à partir de ce
document pour que nous puissions
nous-mêmes avancer sur ces sujets
je vous propose mes chers